le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des Réunionnais les routes
départemental dépendent du conseil
général et la RD41 la route de la
montagne qui avait déjà connu de gros
travaux de sécurisation il y a quelques
années en fait partie aujourd'hui elle
fait pet neuve avec notamment la filière
boî de goyavier pour un fleurissement et
une végétalisation sur près de 5 km
au-delà de son esthétisme cette route
offre un environnement agréable créant
du lien social l'embellissement de cette
route est source de convivialité et
s'inscrit dans le cadre des politiques
départementales en matière d'insertion
qui sont les personnes qui travaillent
sur l'amélioration de cette route quelle
est l'organisation de ce projet on en
parle tout de suite dans lien
social le glve dispense gratuitement ses
services auprès de personnes en
difficulté sociales et ses actions sont
financés par le Département de la
Réunion les agents affectés à l'ensemble
de ces prestations sont employés en
contrat aidé il s'agit en particulier de
public en difficulté bénéficiire des
minimas sociaux chômeurs de longue durée
l'objectif étant de les inscrire dans
une démarche d'insertion et de
professionnalisation mais ce n'est pas
l'unique mission du glve et certains de
ces agents ont en charge
l'embellissement des rampes de la
montagne la RD41
leur mission préserver la richesse et la
diversité des espaces naturels avec un
retrait des pestes végétales autour des
espèces à protéger rendre pérenes des
espaces récréatifs et touristiques et
enfin mettre en valeur des paysages
culturels avec la création de massifs en
aménageant les abords sur des zones
spécifiques et une revitalisation
générale des virages Nelson
nous explique son rôle et comment
comment le projet se déroule le projet
c'est de bon d'aménager tout le site
d'embellir je dirais le site et de le
nettoyer ma mission ici c'est de
dispatcher nos agents sur les différents
sites à aménager ainsi que de faire
rentrer toutes les matières premières ce
qu'on fait c'est que on nettoie d'abord
le site puis on on fait passer d'abord
la miniel ensuite pour pouvoir nettoyer
nettoyer un peu plus le terrain pour le
rendre je dirais praticable les équipes
j'ai choisi les agents des agents qui
sont déjà qualifiés et formés pour ce
type de de ce type de travaux donc on
monte nos facines à l'intérieur de nos
facines on revient on met de la terre et
par la suite nous allons planter des bon
différentes plantes des plantes
qui qui sont adapté à ce type de terrain
le projet é allé sur 3 mois on a
commencé de on va dire du boulevard du
pont vinsan jusqu'au TR bon Bernard
rivière travaille sur ce tronçon de
route il en est très fier il propose aux
usagers de s'arrêter pour admirer c'est
un ancien dugave quoi et depuis 2007
2008 2009 et du coup ben après était de
3 années en au chômage a signé un
contrat avec le glve depuis le 18 pour 1
an renouvelable 1 an maintenant pour
réhabiliter le le secteur la montagne
les Romes de la montagne qui prend un
que des gens de Marie la montagne pour
pour aménager pour pour structurer pour
faire un petit peu pour planter et après
bonè après les gens va respecter aussi
on aura on aura un peu le le service ça
arrache pas les plantes que nous nous
plant parce que est pas évident
travaille au soleil c'est quand même
assez dur quand même pour nous quoi pour
nous et pour toute l'équipe ça tient
cœur vraiment parce que je pense que si
la journée n est là c'est pas c'est pas
pour rien nous donne la nous à fond et
c'est aussi pour les les habitants de la
montagne ici ça qu' monent ils
descendent tu vois un peu le paysage
comment il est et il fait bon aussi de
temps en temps et arrête dans les rampes
arrête dans les rampes et voilà regarde
un petit peu et le paysage et même pour
picniquer à la rigueur sur le C là
Jean-Claude despêche âgé de 52 ans est
en contrat d'insertion au Glèves depuis
2 ans il aime son travail j'ai toujours
vécu à la montagne en fin de compte j'ai
connu cette route qui était encore au
niveau pavé avec le bus courant d'air et
aujourd'hui quand je vois qu'il y a il a
une équipe qui pense encore la route de
la montagne mais moi ça me fait plaisir
j'ai fait un contrat
de 6 mois à 22h et ensuite le contrat a
renouvelé un an et en 35h mais en tant
que sous-chef ça fait que j'ai eu la
chance de quand je suis rentré ici de
tomber sur quelqu'un qui était vraiment
que compréhensif je parle de mon chef
d'ailleurs ça fait 2 ans et demi on est
on travaille ensemble
et c'est qui du bonur c'est un travail
qui m'a toujours que j'ai toujours aimé
c'est c'est mon domaine le bois la forêt
l'immeuble la ville c'est pas mon truc
ça m'a redonné envie de presce que envie
de vivre parce que il m'a permis à 50
ans à 52 ans d'avoir un travail chose
que on trouve pas partout en fin de
compte j'ai déjà fait avoir beaucoup de
gens que j'adore ce travail j'aime ce
que je fais je vais continuer pour pour
pour regardarder jusqu'à jusqu'à la
retraite en fa j'ai pas passé un Capp
j'ai pas il faut pas faire des études B+
5 il suffit d'aimer et puis voilà les
actions conjointes du conseil général et
du glive permettent aux usagers et aux
touristes qui empruntent quotidiennement
cette route d'y trouver un paysage en
adéquation à avec l'image que représente
l'île de la Réunion ce sont des jeunes
et des moins jeunes en insertion
bénéficiaires du RSA qui l'ont entretenu
et qui l'ont valorisé cet embellissement
est un exemple de solidarité sociale
mise au service de la solidarité
économique il offre un emploi et un
savoir-faire à des réunionnés en
insertion ils participent au bien-être
des usagers de cette route tous ces
agents qui travaillent dur peuvent être
fier de passer sur ce chemin et se dire
moi j'ai travaillé là vous aurez
certainement un autre regard lorsque
vous emprunterez cette belle Route
fleurie et arborée admirez et respectez
ces beaux espaces et le travail accompli
en ramassant vos déchets pour le bien
vivre ensemble et bonne route à
tous le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais